your surgeon will perform hysteroscopy
to view the inside of your uterus
hysteroscopy can be used to diagnose or
correct a problem in your uterus without
needing to make an incision in your
abdomen
the uterus is a hollow organ in your
lower abdomen where a baby grows during
pregnancy
each month during a woman's childbearing
years the inner layer of her uterus
called the endometrium builds up with
extra blood and tissue to prepare for
pregnancy when pregnancy does not happen
the extra tissue sheds through the
vagina during menstruation
a diagnostic history osku P maybe done
to evaluate causes of abnormal uterine
bleeding investigate possible causes of
infertility or repeated miscarriages or
detect benign or non-cancerous growths
in your uterus like fibroids polyps
scarring or malformations an operative
hysteroscopy may be done to remove
benign growths from your uterus obtain a
tissue sample or biopsy from the lining
of your uterus locate an intrauterine
device or IUD or place small devices in
your fallopian tubes as a form of
permanent birth control before your
procedure you may be given general
regional or local anesthesia
your doctor will begin by inserting a
speculum to spread open the walls of
your vagina your doctor will then pull
the cervix toward the entry of the
vagina next your doctor will use
instruments called dilators to open up
your cervix
your doctor will guide a history scope a
thin device equipped with a camera and
light through your vagina and into your
uterus the camera transmits images of
your uterus to a screen your doctor will
inject gas or fluid to expand your
uterus making it easier to locate
abnormal tissue in your uterus in a
diagnostic history osku p your doctor
will use the history scope to examine
the inside of your uterus in an
operative hysteroscopy your doctor will
insert small tools through the history
scope to take a biopsy remove a growth
such as a polyp or treat other problems
after the procedure your doctor may
recommend medication for pain relief you
should be able to return to your normal
activities within one to two days after
your procedure you may have mild
cramping and some bloody discharge for
several days